hello guys my name is eterno and welcome
back to another civilization episode so
today we're going to continue off with
where we left off last time which was
with this kind of database digitization
right so d civilization of course is the
process of kind of going going from that
serialized form of that byte stream that
we just created back into an actual kind
of object structure that we can access
in our program that is useful to us
right because whilst a stream of bytes
is fantastic for storage or
transportation it's very very unwieldy
to kind of have like when we're actually
trying to use it so that that's that's
why this whole concept of D
serialization exists so we'll continue
on so in in our database class we
managed to make this method called the
serialize and then this digitalized from
file which would simply just read the
file and then jump over here into the
deserialized method so what we did here
was we basically just read in a few kind
of vital features and we found out that
we were able to extract nice information
such as the name of our database which
was called database because we printed
the name and also we basically were able
to fly it to find out stuff like the
name length or rather the size of the
database and how many objects it had and
and all that stuff and if you look at
the structure of our actual database
file that's pretty much all we have so
the step this step that we're really up
to now is actually going through those
objects right so how do we get the data
out of the objects and the way that
we're going to do that is actually
pretty simple we're gonna kind of
delegate each of this each of these
digitalisation steps to their
appropriate class so you can see that
the deserialized method that we have
here in our c database returns a new
database right here it is a creates a
new database it fills up all of these
kind of fields that are in the database
and then when it comes to these kind of
dynamic
lists of other civilization objects that
we have such as this RC object class
we're actually going to hop on over to
the RC objects deserialize method that
we that were just about right now and go
through that the other thing that we
have to kind of think about is this list
of objects right we actually do have an
object count yeah we have multiple
objects and we can't just say how's the
object can you return to me a list of
objects I mean theoretically we could do
something like that but it kind of would
make more sense for an RC object to
return a single object much like a
database of course returns a single
database so if we hop on over into RC
object we'll make a method down here
called public RC object deserialize now
of course it's going to take in both our
stream of bytes right which is our data
what do we call it here
Darla's sure and then of course is going
to have to take in some kind of pointer
to the beginning of that data okay
and all of this is going to do is is
going to fully destroys a single object
judging by the data that we have
available to it with this offset and
then it's gonna return it and that's it
and the database in fact is going to be
the one in charge of saying oh actually
there are more there's more than one
right so basically what I'm saying is
for each of these objects that we know
we have based on object count
we need to repeatedly call RC object up
to deserialize and that's all we need to
do also I'm sorry I'm kind of using I'm
kind of mixing up Java conventions here
with kind of my conventions and what I
do the rule the only rule that I'm
employing you might have noticed it by
the way is when I'm using static methods
that actually return a new instance of a
class or of the class that they're in
I'm using kind of capitalized letters
here so you can see get size get bias
out object they're all kind of they're
all kind of inside this RC CC database
class and they're all member just member
function
right there oldest methods in our
ization rider we have some static
methods but they're still just like that
is plain old kind of functions right but
then if you look at something like RC
object you'll see oh I see yeah Asli
object is a good example you'll see
these kind of create functions or I
think this was an Elsi field actually
you'll see all these kind of create
functions which actually do return a new
instance of the type that they're in
those are kind of just capitalized just
for readability okay you know if this
wasn't Java I'd probably be capitalizing
absolutely everything but I do still
respect that convention so I'm not but
that's just how I I like to roll all
right
anyway so deserialize how do we do this
well if we look at our C database a good
way to start is with something like this
right so let's take a look this data
data at pointer Ryan should be the this
this whatever this returns should be at
the beginning of the very first field
that we have here which is container
type so the first thing we should do is
just assert to make sure that container
type is indeed what we want and that
container type also happens to be a byte
so we can just say data will always
increment that pointer after we read
from it we'll just make sure that data a
pointer is equal to our container type
right just a quick assertion that we're
actually in here right that that that's
again just a little debug thing that we
can do just to make sure hey you are
indeed trying to dis utilize the correct
object okay we are in the correct
deserialized function and so you can see
that's kind of what we did here so well
we did the widget with the header really
would be container type assertion here
in fact I think I might actually rewrite
it like this so I might say something
like bytes container type container type
equals that and then I'll just do
container type like that just so that
it's a bit more eatable okay after that
we've got let's take a look here we've
got the name length and the name so how
do we do that here I think we just
really did
okay I guess we did reads train for that
no what am I looking for
name laying from the name again I'm just
gonna kind of steal that so at this
point once we've asserted that that that
is correct we'll make a new instance
here that will return with a result new
RC object right
we'll make that new constructor here
that's a private constructor that is
just the default constructor it takes no
parameters whatsoever and then we'll
paste this in so that is looking pretty
good you can see we didn't even have to
change anything that should be
extracting our name right after that
we've got these sighs okay so we need to
reading the size and again that will
just be as simple as saying result dot
size equals read int because it is an
int data pointer and that's it or in
fact how do we do this because this okay
I guess we just need to make sure that
that is indeed four bytes I guess or
rather pointer so we've got the size now
which is good because now we can kind of
say by the way the the purpose of this
as well is just to just to be like well
if we wanted to now skip everything we
could kind of say something like pointer
plus equals you know sighs - you know
kind of the rest of this so it would
really be probably - like one bite for
the container type - the name length
whatever that was or two bytes for the
name length - the name length and then -
four bytes for the size and then if we
did something like this then we we could
just literally say return null and like
we choose not at the zero has that
object right so that's that's an example
of where that size kind of is use kind
of is useful as well you could also
store something that says well yeah I
mean this is probably to sound a way to
do it but we're not interested in we're
not interested in that right now we
might add that as an as a bonus feature
but for now
everything is looking good so we'll say
the field count is next right so result
dot field count equals read short data
pointer and pointer plus equals two and
now we go into our fields right so this
year Elias fields here
I've called little to do here then we'll
do the so what do we have we've got the
string count and the array count so we
do that and then we have the string
count we're just going to be the next
thing and then we have the array counts
okay so we just realized our arrays here
and our strings here okay and they're
going to be really important because of
course they do contain the correct data
that we need to kind of move that point
or a long so this is exactly what I'm
talking about right if we did want to
actually decide that okay ask the object
result you know this I've read the
object the objects name this is an
object that I actively now want to
deserialize we actually have to go ahead
and say something like you know let's
step into the deserialize function for
RC field our C string and our C array
right there's a lot of stuff to do
whereas with this size again as I said
we could just be like if this isn't what
we want to do we can kind of skip all of
this deserialization and go on to the
next object okay that's what that's what
we're kind of gonna do now we're gonna
test that theory out just to make sure
that we can maybe extract all of the
names of the objects from our database
now at the moment I think there's only
one object and it's called entity right
but we'll just verify that anyway and
we'll maybe add in another object to
test as well so once we've read in the
size right we can say private final int
size offset or something like that again
I don't know why I've chosen that but
we'll say one plus two
plus we'll have to add in the name
length and then plus full right so now
all we can do is we can really just say
point a plot pointer plus equals size
offset minus the size of the name or the
name length right and if we do something
like that now we return null for example
or we can just return the result up to
where we kind of we're at and if we just
add an if true here Java will not give
us an error for that we should be able
to kind of be at the point where we can
destroy something else so in this case
we'll just return null or we can just
return result I guess as well okay cool
so let's test this out and make sure it
works the way that we'll do that is we
will go back into our digitization test
and we will say all the other thing is
we're only supporting one object right
so this is what we need to do once we
determine the object count we need to
say for INT i 0 is less an object count
i plus plus that we can do serialize
every single one of those objects right
this is supposed to be resolved object
count okay we can just say something
like results dot objects don't add right
are see object dot deserialize which
just is not coming up wise okay it's not
static let's make that static size
offset becomes static as well okay cool
so we'll say will destroy eyes that the
data will be data pointer will be the
pointer and we should be all good to go
now the other problem we have here is
that we have no idea what a point on our
ears so we need to somehow take that in
and that's just really annoying because
I can't really pass it by reference
that's just so annoying that
this is why I don't like this waiter
like Java alright sure well we could
convert into a new integer object in
fact if we do that is it just going to
work by reference
it might I actually don't know I've
never try this before but maybe if we do
that it will actually just you know have
our data kind of and maybe if we do
something like integer pointer object
equals new integer I guess we could
either do that I will pass it by an
array I'm honestly not even sure which
option would be better but if we do that
I'm sure that we could then set point or
equal to point to object dot value or in
value or something like that right if we
really wanted to anyway now yeah so that
should essentially digitalize everything
so if we go back to and then objects the
last thing we've got so if we go back to
main and we do something do something
like for int I equals 0 is less than
database dot objects or whatever they're
called which I assume are private let's
make them public everything should
really be public here this is more like
a struct let's all say database start
objects dot size I plus plus or I can
even just have a 4h loop here if I
wanted to and we'll just say you know
what let's print out the name of objects
so we'll say let's format this starter
base and we'll say let's get me the name
of the database or I think get name
would be better
okay so database dot objects don't get I
we probably don't need to make if we
were really I guess we don't need to
make object counts or slides I think
public but I don't want the objects to
be public
get I don't get named which we don't
have yet
so let's copy that get name into our see
object so set name we'll do a little get
name and then this will just print out
if we print out a tab here as well just
to advance that there we should be able
to get a list of objects so if we just
run this let's see what happens
okay cool that looks pretty good we're
printing the name out again let's rerun
that so you can see that we get the
database with the name database and then
we have an object called entity which as
you can see exactly what we wrote in
here
so let's mix this up a little bit let's
add another object so I'll literally
just and it will be an empty object so
I'll just say database add object new RC
object name we'll call this Cherno all
right that's all we'll do and then we'll
still eyes out bytes so we'll do the
sterilization test and then straight
after we'll just do the digitization
test so it's running to test dot ICD and
you can see that that's what we're
reading back ok looks pretty good so
let's do that
okay so we got entity and then we got
entity again so I wonder if that's
something to do with our kind of string
situation because that if we didn't
advance the pointer that's what we would
have gotten we probably didn't actually
this is why I assume that if we went
into us the object and we said point to
plus equals to that
I don't know how to I'm not sure if this
overrides actually work anyway
I I don't know I'm just gonna go back to
using an array honestly she'd done that
from the beginning point to ref we'll
call it so int pointer is going to equal
pointer ref one zero and then at the end
so like here for example will say point
to raffles pointer pointer ref is zero
Eagles pointer and then we'll return
which means that out here when we do
something like this we can just say that
we have point ref which is a new int
with one in there which is just going to
be the pointer right and then of course
we'll just set the pointer back - oh we
could even just bring this out here if
we really wanted to not create an array
every time which is probably a much
better idea
so yeah that'll just have our point a
ref and then we can just kind of yeah
read that back there and everything
should hopefully work so if we run that
now well well well what have we got here
so that clearly didn't work
I wonder if how size was wrong or if I
missed something well we didn't get
entity twice oh that's always good
but we also did not exactly work the way
that I thought we would so let's kind of
go through this break point placed and
let's step through it so what we have
container type is four which is I think
correct right because it means that
we're on where our containers have
stored for means object okay so we're at
the correct kind of position here the
thing that I've been said about is size
so let's just make sure the way I kind
of act
that we've got result name lengthen the
name which we know is correct because it
does print out entity then the size so
that's the one I'm worried about what is
this what is a size we can't even look
at the size that's fantastic does it
tell us anything result size whoa is
that 200,000 that coffee right
why is our size 200,000 that is a bit
odd have I missed something how do we
serialize this contain a name length
name sighs hmm so this should be equal
so what is this oh is 200,000 I guess
that's right and what are we that can't
be right there can it 200,000 bias oh
we're doing the random right let's not
do that let's not do the array the
reason I don't want to do the array it's
because I I want to you know almost be
is it easier to debug
so 179 else that looks better so when we
do serialize that lets go back to here
we get hopefully the correct value back
so which is 179 right okay good so we do
have the right value
we've lost the point by 4 and then we
kind of figure this out so this must be
the issue well if I'd done have I really
oh my goodness that's fantastic
so I actually forgot to I actually
forgot the most important part which was
to actually use the size to figure out
how much we need to offset so that was a
bit embarrassing but jeez that was
terrible ok and then of course this has
to be - size offset so that this is the
size of our entire object so what we
need to do from there is take away the
existing fields that we've read because
we
already advanced the point of that much
right so result of size is something
that we can technically add on to the
actual pointer that comes in okay so if
we now run this and we get rid of our
breakpoints what we should hopefully see
is okay so we've got a crash now which
is fantastic it's a string index out of
bounds exception let's take a look at
where it comes from read string and it
looks like our C object or deserialize
is kind of the issue I'm assuming this
is our second object that we're trying
to deserialize
in here which is I equals 1 yes it is so
the second object is causing a crash
probably because our bites on a line
properly if we take a look at the name
length in fact let's just put a
breakpoint the best place to probably
put a breakpoint is around this
assertion which isn't being run because
I'm not using the right Java flags but
anyway this is the first one you can see
it does pass with a container type of
four and then the next one has a
container type of 104 so clearly we're
in the wrong here
so what that tells me is that this size
is actually not what we want right so
the size that we read in from the
previous one is probably wrong because
it means that our pointer has been
advanced either not enough or too much
so if we go back and we take a look at
what that was actually set to and the
best way to do that is probably I mean
if we look at point 2f
okay so we're 200 right which means that
the size if we just go back here real
quick we set our size to be horizontal
size which is a hundred and seventy nine
so let's open up our file here in a hex
view or are we yeah all right so the
beginning of our of our first object or
our entity right we've got two objects
one is called entity of it the other
ones called Cherno the beginning of this
is right over here with this byte here
this is it's four right which means it's
an object so what we need to do is we
need to measure out 179 bias and see
where we are in the file so if we can
about 179 by
- hex real quick 179 is b3 so b3 I'm
looking at the length down here right b3
is here okay
so we've gotten up to with with length
of b3 means we're up to disk bite here
so it looks like we're a whole three or
so bytes off okay because by getting us
to beat three it means that the PI that
we're kind of beginning to read is by
number 68 so that's an issue because
we're looks like we're four bytes with
we're exactly four bytes off my
suspicion is that we're forgetting to
write out something like size which is
conveniently four bytes in one of these
either in a field a string or an array
that's probably the issue just because
it is exactly four bytes that we're off
by okay so our CR a this size does not
make any sense to me I don't know why
it's here because if we look through
this we have one bytes then we have two
for the short then we have ignoring the
dynamic ones we've got one what for for
the size which is what this is we've got
one for the type per seems to be over
here and we've got just an integer so we
really just have an extra four bytes I
don't know why so let's get rid of that
let's also move the four and the one
around so that it doesn't make sense
and we should be good to go so I'm not
sure why that would have happened but if
we do rerun our code now we should
hopefully see that though we work right
and then we have churner and then we
have entity and you can see that I can
really just go ahead and add any amount
of objects and add anything to them in
fact we should be able to bring back our
array as well and make sure that all
works and there we have it
okay one more thing that I wanted to add
real quick as well as a little
optimization to what we did is we we
made this whole deal where our C object
had to take in this point of reference
and that's of course one one way we
could function here if we wanted to have
this point of it I really like doing
that there is actually an easier way to
do it
if we just pass in a normal pointer and
get rid of this right all we have to do
is instead of passing in this pointer if
we pass in that pointer and then at the
end we simply say pointer plus equals V
R sighs right so if we grab this object
into an object that we just deserialized
we can just say pointer plus equals
object size or object I'll get size and
you can see if that works in exactly the
same way cool
so if we see relies more objects we've
got all those going let's serialize some
more Cherno one two three something like
that you can see that that works
perfectly we can also add some fields to
them for example so let's say that this
sure no two object are see object see
it's going to be this one here I'm gonna
just add a field to it real quick
I'll see field dot bullying why not I
don't think we've tested our bullying
with a name and value then we should
still be getting that same result right
so there we have it we can now iterate
through the names of all of our objects
which is pretty cool so yeah next time
we're gonna take a look at how we can do
serialize probably the rest of our thing
so we've done the objects which kind of
the big parts we now just need to go
through fields strengths and arrays and
we'll probably do all three in one
episode so I'll see you guys next time
make sure you hit the like button if you
enjoy this video and yeah see you soon
bye